herzlich willkommen danke die
Promotion-Tour für ihr neues Album under
the Raider over the top scheint Scooter
ziemlich zu schlauchen Frontmann HP
Baxter ist nicht mal mehr in der Lage
ein zwei Meter entferntes Glas Latte
Macchiato zu greifen
könntest du das einmal freundlicherweise
rüberreichen
Grund für die online-talkshow
klicksum.de die Raver mit einer obskuren
Haarschneidemaschine aus der Reserve zu
locken das ist ein staubsaugendes Haar
Schneide Teil das ist so ein Kopf ganz
sauber und schneide sie ab und ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass das
funktioniert das heißt erst werden die
Folterwerkzeuge gezeigt und dann wird
zum Angriff übergegangen
hallo hallo
unintelligible